how are you and what does it mean to be
here tonight because this is
special this is what giving back really
is about yeah um okay so first of all
debbie allen
um and fame
when i was a teenager i wrote a letter
to her at nbc
because i was watching fame on
television and i was like these people
are too old
i'm actually the correct age and i have
all the skills and talent
so you were like wait a minute i'm your
real i'm the real age and i have all of
the talent
you know i sent it to nbc
it came back return to sender
but through the years
i say all that to say that you know
she's been such an inspiration to me as
an artist in terms of where she started
as a performer
as a dancer
and
has enlarged her territory
on her own
the whole time
you know that is
a benchmark
for us
that come behind her the reason why i am
who i am
is because i stand on the shoulders of
miss allen so
there's that part of it
and then there's the part of the giving
back there's the part of the
in the space that we're in right now
where
it feels hopeless
to see something like this existing
is hopeful
we need to be the change that we want to
see
ain't nobody coming to save us from
ourselves
but ourselves
and that
is what's so magical about tonight
that was so well said and that is so
perfect ain't nobody coming here to save
us but ourselves that is so right all
right i want to run through some news
with you you did the j-lo tribute and
now she's engaged what do you think of
that engagement what do you think of
that engagement well i don't know that
it matters what i think about it but i
love the two of them together and i love
her and i love both of them and
you know i'm glad as a person who
married a man
after being broken up for five years
i understand the dynamic of that
and so i'm happy
that she finally that that they have
gotten back to
the true love that they always had yes
yes yes yes you also were at the oscars
the band has been handed down on will
your thoughts on that
um
you know it's a really rough one for me
it's a really rough one for me you know
because
i don't know that i have the authority
to speak on it
but as a black queer man who has been
dragged through the mud for not being
masculine enough
in this world
you know
being called the cause of the
emasculation of the black man because i
decide to play with feminine silhouettes
in my clothing
it's really disheartening
that the version of masculinity shows up
like that
it's upsetting
it's upsetting and i will be
the black queen
that i am
because if that is the if that is the
representation of what masculinity is
supposed to be i don't need it
well isn't it also something to say that
you have been you stay true to you yeah
you never stopped being true to you i
have never even when the world was like
hey wait a minute you were like no this
is who i am this is who i am this is who
i will always be
and
you know that moment
reinforced that inside of me
you know no shade i know a lot of people
have issues you know
i don't know it's really upsetting
though last thing what are you going to
do tonight because
debbie called on you so what you called
on me and i'm singing a song are you i
am what you sing i'm singing um take the
moment
which is from my broadway album
um
at the corner no
billy's back on broadway i have a lot of
albums
billy's back on broadway
and i'm singing it from that and i'm
really excited